[Música]
o que correria
essa velocidade com que a gente vive tem
lhe permitido viver sentir enxergar
bom eu sempre fui ligada no 220
eu sempre gostei abalei estudei e fiz
muitas coisas e até porque se eu tivesse
uma brecha na agenda
pode ter certeza que eu iria preencher
até porque eu aprendi que na vida
se a gente quer alguma coisa a gente tem
que correr atrás
então a minha vida virou uma correria só
só que de repente nesse ritmo frenético
a vida me pegou de surpresa
a minha avó
a pessoa que me apresentou o melhor dos
mundos
sabe aquela voz que para aquele cantinho
aconchegante para quando você chega às
coisas gostosas para você comer e que
recebe o abraço
assim minha avó ela teve uma complicação
por causa do diabetes e ela teve uma
amputação da perna
daí em diante ela que era uma
empreendedora que era muito dinâmica
viva se sentiu paralisada e entrou em
depressão depois não parou por aí
ela perdeu a visão a fala e já tinha
perdido os movimentos e eu que vivia
naquela vida super agitada
resolvi parar pra aguentar está com ela
naquele momento e foi um tempo muito
especial
foi o tempo de aprendizado de reconexão
de olhar para o outro de uma outra
maneira não foi fácil
foi um período muito triste mas foi
nesse período que eu conhecer melhor as
minhas raízes
as histórias da minha família eu conheci
mais ela ea mim mesmo quando ela se foi
eu que me fez forte por todo o tempo
saber mesmo eu entrei em depressão
daquela de não saírem do quarto ea minha
família que me vi antes tão agitada
ficou preocupada e olhando para aquilo
tudo pensando eu tinha negado o trabalho
tudo que vai fazer agora
então um dia eu resolvi sair de casa com
ar de despedida
olhando tudo que tinha à minha volta e
fui até uma br
decidida a não votar mas chegando lá eu
acho que ela lá de cima falou e ariane
volta vai viver aquilo que a gente
aprendeu juntas né
e foi um estalo de lembrar que eu venho
de família de pessoas fortes
a minha mãe é uma guerreira as minhas
duas irmãs que sempre estiveram do meu
lado em todos os momentos
meu pai que me deu muito amor e eu
voltei por eles e por algo mais que
tinha enxergado naquele tempo todo e eu
voltei que era pra eu voltar então que
fosse diferente fazer diferente
só que esse tempo de escuridão era como
se eu tivesse um lugar muito escuro
muito frio e ali nesse lugar onde eu não
conseguia enxergar o próximo passo foi
onde eu me recolher e reconectar com
quem eu sou a minha essência esse cabelo
era liso longo de progressiva e eu
resolvi ser eu mesmo
[Aplausos]
e nesse tempo e descobrir que eu tinha
uma luz própria
uma luta interior assim como todos vocês
aqui dentro tem independente da situação
que cada um de vocês esteja hoje viveu
outra próximo de alguém que vive todo
mundo tem essa luz e todo mundo aqui
porque cada um de nós veio trazer algo
por esse mundo e que é muito precioso e
descobri isso foi um grande presente
a minha vida é um grande presente e hoje
dou risada mesmo eu sorri com alegria
porque a chance de hoje está aqui neste
chão que me traz força que me dá
segurança e sei quem eu sou
só que voltar não foi tão simples assim
voltei pra casa e tudo que sou daquele
tempo
foi amor das pessoas que me rodeavam
conhecimento e trinta reais no bolso
era tudo que eu tinha mesmo virando
moedinha r$30 e eu me lembrei de uma
época da faculdade que eu sempre gostei
de presentear as pessoas e eu fazia
cadernos artesanais
eu pensei poxa eu tenho um pouco de
material aqui acho que vou produzir os
cadernos e eu vou começar por aqui com
esse dinheiro eu comprei o que faltava e
produzir dez cadernos e era minha chance
de recomeçar
eu levei uma papelaria próximo da onde
eu resido e chegando lá eu fiquei muito
feliz porque a proprietária adorou falou
ao que lindo e eu já fiquei feliz né
oportuniza agosto ela vai comprar e ela
pediu pra ficar em consignação
ok era só 30 e até que voltar de alguma
forma achei que ia demorar meses
mas aquela mesma semana ela me ligou e
disse marianne eu já vendi todos aqueles
que têm uma lista de espera pelos seus
produtos
e foi assim que eu comecei a babá do
design como um negócio social
e a partir disso eu comecei a entender
que o fazer artesanal
o manual apesar de todas as pessoas à
minha volta já que estava maluca por não
vai voltar pro mercado formal
até porque eu era gestora de projectos
viajava bastante coordenava algumas
áreas e as pessoas viviam com uma luta
porque vai fazer artesanato agora só que
eu estava vendo lá na frente que aquele
momento e resgatou de uma depressão era
terapêutico e estava minha renda e nesse
tempo me dei um tempo prazo assim para
dar certo
vai ser um período em que eu vou tentar
mas se não rolar durante este ano eu vou
voltar ao mercado de trabalho e de
repente houve uma chamada para
desenvolver produtos para a cidade de
curitiba onde o resíduo e por sorte por
felicidade nos dois produtos foram
selecionadas
fiquei feliz e na primeira não foi na
época da copa do mundo quem dera ter
brinde extra cidade nesse período
e quando ninguém mais acreditava que na
época da copa e há alguma coisa até
porque curte vai receber poucos jogos a
gente recebeu um pedido enorme a gente
eu porque até então fazer tudo sozinha
mais de mil unidades fazer mil unidades
e produzir artesanalmente em casa eu
falei ok vamos produzir como esse gás
falei agora é tempo daquela correria
voltar era tempo de do ritmo será
acelerado
então eu fiz esses ps pedido era
entregar uma cesta uma quinta feira uma
jornalista me ligou e disse olha a gente
está indo fazer a cobertura para a copa
ea gente vai gravar uma matéria com você
no seu ateliê e feliz né
uau mas mal ele sabia que tudo
funcionava no meu quarto quarto ele e é
eu pensei como é que leva todo esse povo
pra lá
aí passei a noite produzindo e mudando
da sala do quarto para a sala para poder
receber a equipe foi muito legal eu acho
que não pela matéria não foi por estar
na mídia foi porque muitas mulheres
viram essa mata
a partir deste momento se conectar com a
minha história e vieram procurar para
trabalhar nessa grande empresa que até
então estava começando ea partir disso é
reunir algumas mulheres
a gente teve outras demandas no início
eram três
depois eram 10 e o que acontecia
naqueles momentos era que eu encontrei
mulheres na época dos hospitais que não
podiam ir pra casa nem tomar banho
porque não tinha dinheiro pra voltar
elas passavam um tempo cuidando daquelas
pessoas e se esquecendo quem era zero
encontrei mães que queriam acompanhar
seu crescimento dos seus filhos e queria
um trabalho que lhe desse mais chance de
estar mais próximo de aproveitar aquele
momento e olhando para tudo isso essas
mulheres se conectaram ea gente eu
montava os kits ela leva pra casa é
produzido o tempo ela tinha disponível
só que na volta a gente encontrar todas
e naquele momento algo de muito especial
acontecia porque uma em poder a outra
não contava uma história e outra falava
opa
a eta é um esporte muito bacana e ali
tinha algo muito maior então tinha o
artesanato como arteterapia essa
reconexão da e nessa tempo de conversa e
também a possibilidade de renda
a gente cresceu em 2016 que vem eu vou
2015 foi muito legal 2016 eu quebrei
bonito tinha errado no plano de negócio
tudo aquela playoffs fazer de uma
maneira tive que me reconectar e tentar
entender como eu iria trabalhar porque
tinham muitas e muitas mulheres me
procurando e eu não conseguia atender a
todas
foi aí que eu entendi que eu podia mudar
e podia ver essas mulheres com a
potência que elas são porque elas criam
e recriam e transforma suas vidas
a gente não puder a ninguém a gente só
reconnect as pessoas para chegar talvez
algo que elas não viram e elas é que
tinham que ser empreendedoras e não está
trabalhando com alguém então o objetivo
da bdo foi levar uma tecnologia social
da metodologia que a gente aprendeu ao
longo do tempo para que essas mulheres
fossem as empreendedoras as
protagonistas da sua própria história
assim como eu
e eu posso dizer e se vocês me
perguntarem se ainda hoje o povo
sim eu corro mas é bom correr muito
diferente
antes era como uma fórmula 1 tudo
passava em um daqueles cinza de
velocidade de fazer e agora não agora é
como passear de bicicleta
eu fico degustando as coisas eu falo eu
sinto com muita consciência e com muita
presença
eu continuo correndo nem todos os
lugares eu consigo está eu gostaria de
estar com mais amigos é quando a gente
olha aquela notificação e celular e
aquele monte de mensagens né
a gente fala porque a gente corre tanto
né a gente corre pra fazer muita coisa
ea gente esquece do essencial
a gente esquece e assim como eu em
alguns momentos eu esqueci de olhar pra
dentro
eu estava me escondendo na verdade por
tudo futuro estava minha volta me
escondendo antes e quando eu comecei a
enxergar e ver que tinha um outro
caminho tudo mudou não só pra mim mas
para as pessoas à minha volta
então se a gente reduzir um pouco a
velocidade
se você puder parar e verificar como é
que você tá
qual é a tua freqüência porque não quer
dizer que você tem que parar geral fica
naquele tempo de escuridão
muito pelo contrário você pode pousar no
seu tempo e saber a hora de voltar para
engatar a marcha e seguir
a gente só precisa se reconecta a gente
está gerando muita coisa a gente antes
comprava ter sido depois a gente viu que
a gente que hoje a indústria têxtil
descarta em torno de 170 mil toneladas
de tecido ea gente hoje só produtos com
resíduos só com que chega
eu acredito muito que a gente pode dar
valor àquilo que é descartado assim como
pessoas que muitas vezes são vistas como
um resíduo social
acho que todos nós queremos alegria
todos nós queremos viver bem nós não
nascemos com a mentalidade mal a ninguém
o que eu vejo é que a gente está
correndo demais ea gente não tá encher
muita coisa a meu convite é para que
vocês acelere um pouco
olhem pra vocês em que momento de vida
vocês estão
se vocês realmente estão conectados com
essência de vocês
isso é esse caminho que vocês querem e
não tem nada contra isso
também não sou contra pela cidade em
alguns casos é essencial mas eu queria
dizer que eu tenho aprendido nesse tempo
todo é que cada vez que a gente consegue
se conectar com quem a gente é a gente
vai ter algo muito melhor para esse
mundo independente da velocidade
independente do tempo que você tá é
possível mudar
eu acredito muito que eu comecei com um
pouco
hoje a gente já tá indo pra fazer aqui
algumas semanas para 200 mulheres e que
não é o produto final que importa o que
importa são as pessoas que estão se
vendo se respeitando seu ritmo a sua
frequência e essa velocidade
eu convido vocês olharem para as coisas
simples da vida nem na sua essência com
muito propósito com muita verdade
e não esqueçam sejam muito felizes
porque a vida é curta a gente não
precisa correr muito porque a gente
corre a gente chega lá está quase no fim
dessa vida né que pode ter um outro lado
vamos ser feliz
vamos nos reconectar e eu espero que
esse tempo seja pra vocês muito especial
e que vocês consigam entrar esse
presente só vocês vieram trazer obrigada
[Aplausos]